David Boder: [In English] This begins a short interview with Monsieur Malfis Marson, a French Jewish citizen.
David Boder: [In German] Monsieur Marson, äh, wo sind Sie geboren?
Malfis Marson: [In French] Je suis né à Paris.
David Boder: [In German] Äh, wollen Sie mir bitte erzählen für unsere amerikanische Freunde, äh, wie was Sie getan haben during the den Krieg und die deutsche Okkupation.
Malfis Marson: [In French] Durant la guerre, j’ai été comme tout Français mobilisé. J’ai fait l’Occupa...j’ai fait...une partie de la guerre dans les Corps Francs. Ensuite sur accident, j’ai été évacué dans le centre de la France. Jusqu’au moment où, la grande offensive allemande s’est déclenchée, qui m’a trouvé dans un hôpital de la région limousine, à Périgueux exactement. Je suis parti ensuite en convalescence. Et au mois de...au début de juin, et j’ai rejoint mon dépôt dans la Mayenne. Par la suite de l’avance des armées allemandes, j’ai été évacué de ce dépôt, avec le reste du dépôt naturellement, et nous nous sommes dirigés vers la Bretagne, où nous avons été faits prisonniers le 18 juin exactement. Par la suite, je me suis évadé en septembre 40. Pour rejoindre la zone libre, parce qu’étant...premièrement prisonnier de guerre et deuxièmement juif, je ne pouvais pas rester à Paris sous l’Occupation. Je suis...est-ce que je continue ?
David Boder: Continuez.
Malfis Marson: Arrivé en zone libre après quelques péripéties, je me suis inquiété n’est-ce pas, de pouvoir trouver une occupation, j’ai repris mon ancien trav...mon ancien métier. Qui était tailleur avant la guerre, et j’ai travaillé...à Périgueux. J’y suis resté jusqu’en ’43. Je peux vous dire qu’entre temps, j’avais pris contact avec les organisations de Résistance, en ’42, l’organisation Francs Tireurs zone sud, où je faisais pas mal de propagande-diffusion. Au début ’43, j’ai été contacté par le mouvement Combat, et j’ai pris à ce moment l’organisation départementale des liaisons. La gestapo ayant réussi à nous...dépister, en mai ’43...j’ai réussi de justesse à leur échapper, et je me suis réfugié dans le maquis.
David Boder: [In English] What I want to know...how did the Resistance movement form itself? Was that the old French radical party...How did the Resistance movement come about? How did it organize?
David Boder: [In German] Wie hat sich die ganze [unverständlich]
Interpreter: [In French] Quels mouvements politiques ont participé à la création de ce [inaudible] ?
David Boder: [In German] Ja, wie hat sich die Resistenz gebildet? Wer, waren es die alten Partien? Ja, ja...
Malfis Marson: [In French] La Résistance de mon point de vue, d’après l’expérience que j’ai vécue par moi-même, a été surtout formée par des mouvements syndicaux et politiques avancés. Par des mouvements politiques, qui étaient excessivement, exceptionnellement antinaz...anti...antifascistes. Qui étaient...il y en avait d’autres qui étaient nationalistes, mais qui étaient antigermaniques parce qu’ils avaient subi l’occupation, et connu les Allemands en 14-18. Et par des gens qui avaient l’esprit...porté à...la liberté tout court. Pour ma part, j’ai premièrement été contacté par des hommes, qui avaient été brimés dans leurs opinions, dans leurs origines, qui avaient...eu à pâtir de certaines vexations. Et qui, de ce fait, estimaient que le premier des devoirs, pour tout Français puisque nous étions en France, je dirais pour tout homme, était de lutter contre l’envahisseur. Mais je peux dire une chose, c’est que...ceux qui nous contactaient étaient des hommes sincères, des hommes qui ont cru que la Résistance pouvait être utile pour que nous puissions être libérés premièrement de l’Occupation, et deuxièmement arriver à devenir de meilleurs hommes et des hommes libres surtout.
David Boder: [In English] Now, how was it...What elements of the population...
Malfis Marson: [In French] Je ne comprends pas...
David Boder: [In German] Was für Elemente der Bevölkerung haben angefangen zu kollaborieren, haben meistens kollaboriert mit die den Deutschen?
Malfis Marson: [In French] Les premiers collaborateurs à mon sens, étaient des ratés. Des hommes qui ont cru à ce moment que leur heure était arrivée, de grands jaloux, des hommes qui n’avaient eu aucun avenir devant eux, et qui se figuraient que la bestialité de leurs sentiments, non pas de leurs sentiments mais de leur appétit, de leurs instincts allait se trouver assouvie et qu’ils allaient arriver, comme Hitler, à dominer, je ne dirais pas le monde, mais la France et peut-être l’Europe avec l’aide d’Hitler. Par la suite, d’autres gens ont été découragés par le manque de...je ne dirais pas de la résistance mais enfin...nous nous sommes aperçus que les pays alliés n’étaient pas suffisamment préparés à ce moment, et il y en a qui ont été découragés, qui ont cru que vraiment l’Allemagne allait dominer le monde, et ils se sont, par faiblesse et par lâcheté, donnés dans ce...accepté cette collaboration. Et il y en a eu d’autres, par intérêt, à proprement parler, par...
David Boder: [In Russian] Эээ...энд...эээ...мистер...эээ...господин [unintelligible]...эээ...спросите его вот что: эээ...в этой...как относились к этой станции военные?
Interpreter: [In French] Quelle était l’opinion des cercles militaires, et quelle était leur participation dans les mouvements de résistance ?
Malfis Marson: Elle a été pour ainsi dire nulle au début. Parce que les militaires étaient, à mon point de vue n’est-ce pas, les militaires étaient disciplinés, à part quelques rares militaires français de carrière qui ont suivi de Gaulle, je ne dirai pas au début mais dans les mois qui suivirent sa déclaration du 18 juin ’40, ils étaient tous inféodés à Vichy parce que, le militaire par essence même, est un être discipliné qui est obligé...qui obéit à son supérieur, et pour eux le maréchal Pétain était le chef suprême de la force française. Par la suite, ils se sont...grandis, ils ont...il y en a certains qui ont pas mal saisi puisque les premiers fondateurs des mouvements de résistance et en particulier de combat ont été des officiers de carrière évadés qui ont pris une action...qui ont pris...qui ont fait...qui ont...qui ont accompli une action assez forte en France. Mais jusqu’à...le débarquement en Algérie, on peut dire que les militaires français de carrière n’ont absolument rien fait dans les mouvements de résistance. Et que les mouvements de résistance ont été uniquement montés par des membres civils, par des membres des partis politiques et surtout les organisations syndicales et ouvrières françaises.
David Boder: [In Russian] Эээ...спросите его вот что: если он знает, как была интеллигенция, например университетские профессора и...эээ...вообще профессиональные люди, как адвокаты, врачи...и...эээ...эти...эээ...судьи и так далее?
Interpreter: [In French] Quel était le rapport entre les mouvements de résistance et quelle était l’action de résistance des intellectuels français, tels que les simples universitaires, les avocats, les médecins, enfin tous les représentants des professions libérales ?
Malfis Marson: Euh...la jeunesse étudiante française...au début de l’Occupation a réagi vigoureusement. On a eu quelques manifestations le 11 novembre ’40, pour préciser, où il y a eu pas mal de bagarres entre les forces occupantes françaises...et les...le quartier latin, je crois, tu t’en rappelles de ça ? Sur le boulevard euh...sur le boulevard Saint-Michel. Par la suite on peut dire que, une grosse partie des étudiants français ont été parmi les éléments dirigeants et parmi les éléments les plus actifs de la Résistance française. Quant aux intellectuels arrivés, il y en a eu je crois des deux côtés, et au début une grosse partie a collaboré, malheureusement...Ah, certains professeurs...certains professeurs, et on peut dire ça à leur honneur, ont été parmi les éléments les plus actifs de la Collab...de la...de la Résistance. Il y en a eu d’autres, très peu, qui ont collaboré.
David Boder: [In Russian] Эээ...[unintelligible]...и как фармеры...эээ...агрикультурное население, как оно относилось к этой станции?
Interpreter: [In French] Quelle était la position de la population paysanne...[inaudible]...envers la Résistance ?
Malfis Marson: Envers la résistance ? La position paysanne envers la Résistance était encore assez bonne dans son ensemble. Il faut dire une chose, c’est que le tempérament du paysan français est un tempérament uniquement individualiste, et égoïste, il ne voit que son intérêt. Mais je crois qu’il est surtout patriote, et ce qu’il n’aimait pas, c’était certaines impositions forcées qu’on lui imposait, n’est-ce pas. Mais dans le fond, je crois que...malgré le programme que Pétain et Vichy avaient élaboré en sa faveur, il a aidé avec le maximum de chance, les éléments de la Résistance qui se sont adressés à lui.
David Boder: [In English] How does he think will the situation now clear up in France and how will life become organized and what he expects when will France be back to normal?
David Boder: [In Russian] Как он ожидает, как он думает теперь: все это положение придет к нормальному и как скоро это будет нормально?
Interpreter: [In French] Qu’est-ce que tu penses de la situation actuelle ? Quand penses-tu que la situation actuelle va redevenir normale et par quels moyens ?
Malfis Marson: A la suite de la guerre, naturellement, il y a pas mal de...de désorganisation, dans les moyens d’échange et de production en France. Je crois que, de mon point de vue, tant qu’il n’y aura pas d’accord complet entre...les ouvriers d’une part, les patrons de l’autre, au moyen des productions d’échange, et pour essayer de limiter le marché noir et...de régulariser n’est-ce pas, la distribution de tous les produits essentiels et nécessaires...à la...à la vie, on ne pourra pas voir un retour...on ne pourra pas revenir, n’est-ce pas, à la période que nous avons vécue en 38 et en 39. Pour ma part, je crois qu’il faut qu’il y ait une collaboration féconde, je ne dirais pas non seulement avec les Etats-Unis mais surtout l’Europe elle-même.
David Boder: Merci beaucoup Monsieur Marson.
David Boder: [In English] This finishes a brief interview with Monsieur Malfis Marson of the French Resistance Movement taken at the Schools of ORT on July 30, 1946. Eh...how old is he? [Ends abruptly].